welcome to this video playing FM sent to
which sent to which from Iceland CQ
beyond beyond song okay so we have a
king's gambit and i'll play the sharpest
line I mean I really for tend to forget
everything about it but let's try that
g5 I really think that this is the best
line objectively speaking but I tend to
forget things ok Knight f6 here or d6
think it both AB it's both good right
Knight f6 here there is a days Bishop c4
this crazy line ok let's do with it that
let's do this that's not not bad at all
again that's exactly my problem I keep
forgetting how this is blade is it rook
g8 here on what is the move Bishop age 6
is also a possibility at some point ok
I'll start with root G ATM probably is
totally screwing this up d for bishop
age 60 ml I need to keep the pawn
otherwise this doesn't make any sense at
all night c6 problem
yeah that's the good thing if you play
an opening like the Kings get mad you
you probably know from the get-go that
you're going to have a crazy position so
you can easily sacrifice even g2 not
quite sure what happens but I'll just
take it I don't see why I should why I
shouldn't take it ready
yeah I just need three moves and I'm
winning Bishop d7 Queenie seven long
castles and wide resigns the question is
do I actually get it in I'm I really
don't know what White's next move should
be very app very difficult Queen f3
those rook g3 does not make any sense
which maybe I'm just threatening Knight
g4 forcing matters hmm yeah what is the
point Bishop t2 probably trying to try
to guess along but I have this Nigeria
DM still and have also night before by
the way just attacking the Queen here
isn't this strong by the way where is he
going with the Queen I always have
concrete ideas Queenie 294 by the way
and what does he do now going all the
way back I go 94 after that check oh
this i blundered but I'm I doubt that
this is really good yeah I can just take
him check okay so i have d 5 or B should
be six if I go there should be six Queen
beef name no no no we should be six what
is he playing d 5 I can also play pawn
to 545 Queen takes before
yeah but it's it's a son doesn't matter
rly if he takes here i have this move i
have moves like Queen to g8 and just
threaten as threatened rook takes f2 and
rook g1 it just looks like a really
dangerous attack okay so i can take this
noah and night XD form check would be
really strange if this shouldn't win the
game somehow Queen Queen G tool broke
everyone the shot f Bishop Bishop age 3m
should age 3 is one of the one of the
good moves now it should isn't this
inmate he does not he have he has a
check here this could could be a problem
but i also have f3m i have f3
threatening Queenie to and threatening
f2 yeah that's too much
yeah it's always a bit crazy having this
rook opposite the king but yeah all
general considerations are irrelevant
phew you made him nothing that's it
yeah I'm very often this is the real
issue of the Kings gambit it's not like
you're giving up just the pawn and shown
but you're very often give up the whole
the whole position your King position I
mean yeah yeah there's only night g one
possible white resigned yeah that's very
often really the Kings gambits problem
if you look at the gesture just I mean
this it's a very concrete opening but if
you're just on general terms look at
this white has played H for this is this
is full of weaknesses this position of
course like has some issues as well in
terms of weaknesses but wyd very quickly
em can can get attacked here with some
yeah I must admit that I really forgot
the forgot the opening this is this is
no one I believe but probably knight c6
now and I can I cannot really remember
Luke g8 doesn't this didn't look too
stupid but maybe it has some drawback I
really don't I really don't know the the
precise theory of it yeah and here well
this is just not working i believe i can
just take that and there is no
compensation whatsoever okay look g3 is
even better according to the computer
why exactly the Queen goes all the way
back then I g-force winning in okay
because there's also this yeah that's
even better but ok well my move is minus
for the other movies minus five so check
nothing that I should check lose much
sleep about get exactly Queen g8 is
winning threatening rook g1 threatening
rook f2 and hear ya exactly this is
winning Queen g2 and here f3 yeah I all
the congos but you don't need to use a
computer to find those moves so I'm no
cheating happening here
yeah I really think that g5 is probably
the best line against the Kings gambit
but it's always yeah it's a very test is
very distinct flavor this line very very
sharp and needs to be played very
carefully if you don't know all the ins
and outs alright thanks for watching